welcome to this video on plane step by
step again and this is some allows an
opening isn't this isn't this this is
I'm confused it isn't this laws and
Spassky or something
hmm I wonder it's not it's not last bus
keyword okay let's just continue to
develop a and lost a hit all of ton of
time trying to recall if it is that game
or not know what did you play a lotta
took a p6 ok yeah well it's a it's
hopefully not not so bad yeah it is
Bishop f3m it it's not really great
stupid yeah okay my soup was basically a
mouse lib so um the fire form is this
impossible yeah it's very very
uncomfortable this position check
okay is giving up the night at least
there's no night coming to d5 anymore of
course not a very nice position yeah but
still I can if you want to play Bishop
f6 don't mind that very much maybe Queen
g7 um get down get the Queen's off
23 or something Quinn f5s also not bad
gaining a move on this weird rook on d3
so I can play nine age 55 I want ok I
should I should try to speed up or
cookie form wait this is Queen the ATM
ok quindi ages awkward
Jim that you get from playing a 6 but
okay it's not this position really it
could have been that could have been
worse pretty sure
I hope I'm okay because I get in b5 at
the end this some helps to tooth to free
my pieces a bit night on e six is
covering is covering c7
okay five is not not especially strong
you
95 yeah it's not exactly great
not sure what maybe not g5 was a better
defense
check
mmm I'm under pressure am g six pins not
helping check maybe I can defend him
yeah it's still worth of course time
warning
yeah I'm getting there okay if I have a
hard time to even get the look back and
I cannot defend this no it's a mess of
all the jeep own is too quick what bad
plush resigns I probably am this was a
very bad game really bad game and b5 was
also bad i mean this is a good counter
play but I must I must go to e7 and
delay that I'm still worse but I'm not
sure I should I should really lose this
if I'm a bit more patient it's difficult
for him to win him down this is really
it's always always the space advantage
and it came due to this silly a6 move
but there are be five is mistimed it's
just a mistimed mr. and set up I wanted
to have some play here but it just
weakens the queenside this was just bad
just bad I must if I go for that I at
least have need to have the King down
and and then maybe try that the King
defend something here this is maybe
maybe I'm an idea then be five but I
played it far too far too prematurely
and he I'm just in terrible shape the
combination here I probably should
should have tried no GI and then a for
this is also a loss but maybe candy I
can can still try to fight him that's
its it's clearly better for watching
should be winning again I guess right
thanks for watching